oh we're rolling oye guys what's up it's
date fails it's me Kate
we're in the studio I haven't been here
in a month I'm so happy to be back here
everyone complains because I've been
doing a podcast at home and I'm trying
to record it and it sounds like I'm
recording inside a tin can
that happens yeah I do voiceover
auditions and I usually go into the
agency but then I'll sometimes do it for
my iPhone if they need like really fast
and it sounds like I'm hiding in a cave
it's the way Isis records yeah that must
be what they do I hear terrorists are
really big in voiceover these days yeah
oh my god you get well they're blowing
up yeah but it's so bad it's this is the
thing it's not even like I'm doing it on
my phone actually when I was doing it on
my phone it sounded better and then I
was like I gotta up the quality you
don't we don't realize like this stuff
is so I'm touching the walls it's so
important
yes also the mic and he's important we
have a producer here that's important
and then also the microphones that I'm
using I think that's a problem I think
I've been Mike ones yeah they're like
like karaoke machine Mike's you get at
Sam's Club Oscar sing a song after your
set you get him out of goodwill and um
it's like it's like people who do who
think their Chris Rock and drop them
after every joke that's exactly what
we're using so the point is I've been
trying to do it and every time I think
it sounds okay I get like 50 complaints
about the audio so I just know here we
are we're doing it professionally again
I'm gonna do this as often as I can
you listen to the fans I listen to the
fan you can say you don't know they
can't guys my guests today I have you're
like a big repeat now Jack I've had you
on so many times because we go on the
road together a lot Jack's becoming like
a part-time co-host basically and also
now he knows more about my love life
than he's ever wanted like today I took
him with me to buy tampons I was like
yeah I love like that as your love it
knows more about my love life tampons
because I was like oh my god I finally
got my period and he was like thank god
we've been worried like game we're
playing
[Laughter]
so anyway Jack Jr Jack acid or Ian jr.
here and then also my lover I missed you
I can't believe it I have it's been
forever since I'm like a month since a
month we saw each other at Sycamore
tavern for like a second remember that
show that looked like it was a
going-out-of-business sale oh yeah you
had a cute girl with you is that a date
that was a dish she was cute she's a
cutie I liked her she's very cute are
you guys still talking we are still
talking oh nice yeah yeah we we actually
just met before that that night that
yeah seriously she's like a bum before I
don't know we met at a party see that's
the way to do it you know what I think
that's the thing la we don't aren't
social enough out here cuz you know when
I go home to Chicago I'm never on my
phone when I go home to Chicago or what
I'm working in New York because you're
just around p.m. all the time you're not
looking at your phone as much you're not
mean to people you're not last night I
was at a bar here and my girlfriend and
I were sitting at the bar on our phones
on a dating app actually like swiping
through guys in the dating and drinking
yes huh right well we talked about off
off there but yeah hung over nobody
wouldn't that you were doing everything
except the socializing right you guys
had a bin at your houses and then their
complaint hammer like Jack and I both
got laid in the back room yeah that
place was lit last night and people kept
going who are those two chicks in the
corner and we were like we don't by the
way guys my other guest is actor and
comedian Jonathan kite
so what do we got to talk about first of
all the whole city is burning to the
ground
I said Donald Trump is the Santa Ana
winds of our people who don't know what
the Santa Ana winds are they're just
Fanning the flames Santa Ana winds are a
weird thing because people talk about it
like it's mythical but it's so real
people but here's the thing when you
bring them up and by the way for those
of you who don't know we look like
Mordor from Lord of the Rings like think
the world fire the city is there's like
three enormous wildfires going on around
LA right now the Santa Ana winds I'm
trying to think how to explain it's just
these winds that get pushed in from the
east that some people say they aren't
real and then although they come they're
so real they make those are real by the
way
don't make me sick but they do easily
bring so much debris with them and
they're because there's a desert like
obviously there's mountains and stuff
and we're we have the city here but for
the East it's really flat and there's a
lot of desert there yeah so it brings it
in but my my least favorite thing right
now
besides the the burning of Los Angeles
is when you go oh man the Santa Ana
winds are tough and then every like
somebody will try to cut like like we're
having a debate team moment in high
school nobody I don't know man sometimes
the Santa Ana winds are cool yes I like
the breeze I go yeah but not today
no the Santa Ana winds are never good
they literally blow in like dirt and
dust and they make you sick and people
say they make you moody and crazy and I
think so like a full moon like that's my
problem
I just want to blame him last night's
barrage of text messages on the Santa
Ana wind stop hash tagging Santa Ana
wind but it we are literally we are
living in a movie that is starring the
rock yeah it really is nuts here but
like Jack was talking today this is
Larry so I'm not the fire truck you saw
so I'm at the Americana England there's
a fire truck like parked and like it has
like its things out and kids are coming
up to it and then two firefighters are
taking pictures and I'm like timeout
there's a fire yeah those guys are those
are a part of the Kevin Spacey
birthday party so that's ridiculous what
were they doing
are they gassing up no they were just
like just for photo in the middle of a
mall oh my there were like the line of
kids taking pictures and they're like
Santa yeah except there's like 8y heads
on fire yesterday and the [ __ ] was
better than our fire somebody's like
that kid it's crazy
ridiculous funny too like we're talking
about how you can check in places uh you
can check in online to let people know
you're safe you know in parts the
country and Jack is saying he's seeing
people check in like all the way down to
San Diego yeah door near the far 60
miles away that was just telling you I'm
safe I didn't know what fire what fire
right exactly he's your friend who's a
hypochondriac I'm safe from bird flu bro
you're not gonna read the rest of the
post read the whole poster I'll save so
anyway that's what's going on man why
your memes are going on right now I like
crazy dude that's the same picture too I
know I get Trump's America I just put
this out there please this never
happened in Obama's America not these
fires well fire happens every day yeah
but not like this not the exact color of
Trump's hair all the sex scandals and
then this came up maybe it's just like
hey focus on that Jax like Harvey
Weinstein guys like anyway oh my brain I
can't think today guys I am hungover I
went out last night so I did two spots
last night mm-hmm
do you drink on stage I take one up but
I don't really drink I might have a few
sips if I'm doing a full I'm headlining
then a little more oh I always do but I
was like no one's good yeah I don't
drink more than one before us that ever
and usually I'll have like half and then
take the other half up off the stage
because you're tying into yeah yeah I
get really I'm a lightweight
I get buzzed so easily so if I'm like
buzzed at all I feel like my crowd work
sucks yeah I don't I don't drink ever
until I get the page drink much I mean
look at the body come on for your
listeners at home who are can't see this
weird 100 questions where I can see
right now oh yeah sorry oh sure that's
the video the whole like a Tiger Beat ad
yeah it just says Richard Grieco
property of Grieco but no I can't
I drew I'll pick a night where I'll
drink super hard like for holiday
parties
I definitely drink hard Oh your birthday
you were ahead hammer you drink that's
like that's even that's even less
calories than a skinny margarita are we
drinking yeah absolutely
everyone hangover last longer Oh hashtag
blessed so uh no no what what we're
drinking on my birthday we were drinking
iced Turkey I was drinking tequila
you were drinking everything I don't
know you every time I turn around you
had a new dream I drinking like you
don't Gangs of New York there's that
scene where there's just like a grog pit
that they're all just sort of pouring
crap into and there's just woman named
Hellcat Maggie she was a famous person
and then in the movie she like exchanges
ears like real ears or a drink when did
they come first coming to the bar she
pays for a drink with an eel yeah and
they go and they go left or right here
she goes I just give us a drink
I've only seen the movie my life I love
that movie but I've never seen that part
I don't know I lived it I didn't know
could use body parts in there they have
jars on the bar because that's what it
used to do because when they would
collect trophies like in Daniel
day-lewis says in the beginning that
ears and noses will be the trophies of
the day but no one shall touch him and
that was a priest Valley of the Anissa
those healed cross over on because he
respected him yeah and everybody else
you cut off their their nose or their
ears to prove that you killed them and
so on they traded them in the movie for
grog
I drank all the grog I feel like I'm my
birthday I think you honestly you really
did and I like this I like this plan of
killing people and using their ears and
noses to I'll make you a deal
if you kill the guy that I can't stop
talking to oh my and bring me his ear I
will bite you
you know this how's my deposition in
court color bring his nose and get some
coke for the record wouldn't that where
you'd hide it and your nose trophies
yeah we were but you know what though I
will say this uh when I do party hard I
think that I'm a fun drunk you are so am
i I'm a happy drunk
I don't emotional That's not me I'm like
when I'm drinking hard I'm like we're
having a good time like on my birthday
with everybody there I think it was a
really fun night oh my god it was the
best time I'm gonna have a birthday
party Tuesday do you that already is a
lame place yes what we should do crazy I
can't think of I do I know I can oh come
on your party is lit come on ranch is
touristy for people who don't know they
have a ball you can ride but the reason
I was thinking it is because it's right
by the Comedy Store in the Laugh Factory
so comedians can come after their sets
and I'm Tuesday part yeah I know but
like how many people are doing the sets
on Tuesday I don't know whoever's in
town and then it's $4 to park there so
here's what I'll say
the only thing about setup by the way
the the drinks they're all like if Willy
Wonka was an alcoholic which is fine
right and they give out free that's the
good part about it though yeah I love
forgettin can do the cotton candy they
give you there is no joke like three
feet tall oh oh it's crazy the steak and
eggs and they have really good chicken
nachos and that's my favorite food
chicken or not I mean China combination
the chicken nacho like you're trying to
seduce a plate of magic I'm holding it a
birdbath to beat I was that's the truth
I just burped up inside uh hold on
there's things I wanted to
but I actually have but first before I
do that how about I do an ad I gotta do
an ad guys um this is actually cool
because my favorite thing about having
the podcast really is that when I get
ads they send me the stuff in the mail
to try out and that's really in fact I
just got asked to do ads for a tampon
company and they're like we'll send you
tampons every month and I was like I'll
do the ads for free like just tampons I
just collect tampons
I'll try to get on out there Trojan I'm
available
um but today actually this is for equip
you guys probably don't even know what
quip is maybe you haven't heard of it
let's be honest uh you're supposed to
brush your teeth for two minutes
twice a day but do you probably not most
people don't I don't know what your
answer is this is the deal equip is a
new electric toothbrush that looks like
it was designed by Apple it's really
pretty actually it's really it's uh it's
so nice you can display it it comes with
a little display hangy thing for your
bathroom mirror so you put it right out
there it's like a decoration in your
bathroom and it's way more inexpensive
than all the other electric toothbrushes
it's actually only $25 and right now if
you go to get quick calm slash date
fails to get your quip you get your
first refill pack free with your quip
electric toothbrush it's pretty dope
that's get quip GE t qu i p.com
slash date fails for your $25 quip and
your free refill pack now I just think
that it's a good holiday gift ap yeah
you know what I mean it's a subtle
holiday gift it's a sighs it's like your
breath questionable it's a good white
elephant gift honestly it is it really
is and get this this is what I actually
think it's cool I'm not joking I'm lazy
when it comes to buying the refills
oh you got it you got to change him like
every was it three months or three
months exactly so this for five dollars
they send you refills every three months
so you just like keep getting them in
the mail so you never have to remember
to go buy them which is that is pretty
good that's what I'm getting for cruises
from you right yeah
and I mean they're also in every gift
guide this holiday season they're in GQ
Teen Vogue nylon Forbes men's health so
you guys are gonna see them everywhere
so one more time guys go to get quick
calm slash date bills and get your first
refill pack free with equip electric
toothbrush yeah right that's really part
guys trademark I'm doing it right now
I'm starting a podcast and the whole
podcast about [ __ ] they send them so
nobody sent me anything guys so we're
just gonna sit here in silence for an
hour could you imagine your whole
podcast is just you trying out products
oh I would love it you'd be like QVC but
young and hot tonight I see thank you
thank you for saying young so you know
what my favorite thing in the world
Jerry Seinfeld had this great joke about
he was like talking about I wonder if
he's working a bit and the Tonight Show
the other night yeah because people ask
me all the time like do you watch TV and
I say I don't I really don't watch TV I
am except i watch the flex seal
commercials wait what is flexi oh is
that one of those workout things I think
we're doing an infomercial for right I'm
like flexing my seals that that um that
it will block like any hole it's like
they put in their controller flex seal
chicken bone on my vagina that would be
very helpful you gotta see this though
flex seal what do you mean it really
anything so water can't come out nothing
yeah well the bottom of a canoe shut up
I'm telling you flex seal should be this
podcast you can use that for as a form
of birth control I mean yeah but it does
yeah it's permanent well who wants a
temporary non hole on a canoe I would
have sex with this canoe later and this
canoe might want to have smaller canoes
might not be a bad move for me at this
point let's be honest I mean I am making
poor life choices John I can't stop I
can't love you we gotta fix this well
I'll tell you what I did
this is one thing I want to talk about
this isn't about the old guy that I'm
trying to get rid of but oh yeah I asked
out my celebrity crush I asked him out
so I talked about this guy before I told
you who he is you know who he is he's a
musician
I had the hugest crush on and then he DM
me one day amazing and I tried to keep
the convo going but then he kind of like
didn't really respond but then he did go
on tour in Europe so I was like okay
he's super busy we've never even met I
don't expect him to answer yeah you know
so I was never gonna write him and ask
him out and then I had Carly Craig on my
podcast you know Carl okay yeah so she
was on and she's dating this guy who she
had a huge crush on that she was a fan
of from some nickelodeon show and she
was a kid and she they were like DMing
and she was just like yo I think you're
cute let's get a drink or whatever and
they did and now they're like dating
I've met him he's a really nice guy
yeah but so the thing is I always feel
like if you tell someone you're a fan of
theirs and then ask him out it seems
like it sets up a weird dynamic to me so
I never asked out guys well how much
were they talking before she asked him
out um not much at all she just said he
had liked some of her stuff and she
messaged him like yo I see you liking my
stuff thanks and then he was like big
fan she's like I'm a big fan of yours
too we should get a drink or something
like that like that's literally that was
like mutual yeah so how it happened with
mine is he messaged me and said I see
you liking my stuff all the time thanks
for like the love or whatever and then I
wrote back like huge fan and then he was
like oh I checked out your stuff you're
funny so it's kind of similar um but
then I never asked him out and then last
night because I was drawn get depressed
I was like [ __ ] it what have I got to
lose this at the bar no this wasn't like
3 o'clock in the morning he probably
thought I was trying to bang it's
electric so I messaged him on Twitter
god I hope he never listens to this I
messaged him on Twitter and I just said
hey are you back in town we should grab
a drink sometime and he wrote back yeah
I'm here until like I'm here until the
spring I'll take you out to play pinball
and I was like oh I wonder if he knows I
love pinball
I [ __ ] love pinball what's your
favorite pinball
what like the game yeah well I don't
know all the games I just played Sonic
and Metallica when I was in Columbus the
Metallica machine oh the turtles one is
fun have you ever played the magic one
where there's a floating cube in the
middle and like it has it there's a
magnet in the cube so it looks like the
ball floats up to it and no where's that
yeah it's it's it's from like the 90s
it's amazing have you play back to the
future yes we need to find a pinball bar
called coin up or is that that's in
second American army you maybe no but
there's there's one here there's one um
there's AB arcade on Ventura he's at all
I heard that I yeah it's uh yeah yeah
but they're they're kind of popping up
all over yeah I love pinball well so so
he said let's go play pinball and I said
cool sounds good I'm around this weekend
and I sent him my number of course I was
like four I am so he hasn't seen it yet
or he hasn't replied yet but how great
right now hours but so guys if you're
listening hashtag pray for King but
here's the problem here's the one
problem he loves cats so that's the
reason why I never asked him out because
I'm not a cat person and he loves his
cat so much so I already know it's
probably doomed and also I'm such a big
fan what if I go out with him and it
ruins his music for me like I would have
to I would be soda but his by the way
his song is my ringtone I was just gonna
say if it's any of your ringtone what
does cause me I'm on the date with him
and my phone rings and it plays his song
would that be the most embarrassing date
failable hi you would say true to this
podcast
you're right I'm gonna change it as soon
as we're done but the boy named I'll
remember your ringtone oh what do I do
about the catch I pretend I like cats
look I hate cats
I don't like allergic I like cats he
sleeps with a hairy those are good you
take selfies with it in bed with him he
probably [ __ ] oh you actually it's
like wait you act like it's like a Nazi
that he's hanging out with is that a
member of the alright it's just it's
just not a dog maybe alright you see
with a dog it's cute cat
I don't know I know people are not I'd
see I had a dog but I grew up with cats
so I like them both
yeah and won't hate them well it feels
like you do they just I don't feel
comfortable sharing a bed with it well
that cat came the only [ __ ] in my biz -
you got there first [ __ ] I don't know
so you're okay with you would date a
girl that sleeps with her cat no yeah
I've done that would you share the way I
sleep so they're not the way that Jack
was referring but I just mean like no no
that just yeah but like the cat it sort
of just goes where you know what I mean
like a cat's are always on an agenda
that no one else has seen you know I
mean it like that they always like go do
things whereas like a dog is very
consistent a dog like waits for you it
goes to bed it gets up with you you go
on walks there's like a consistency
whereas like like my parents have a cat
and there is no consistency their cats
just like ah now it's on a chair and now
it like does this thing I mean now wants
to go to bed and you're just like it's
11 a.m. you're right cats have no
consistency maybe that's why they drive
me crazy just like the men I date yeah I
want consistency that's what I realized
that's what I realized I realized it
from this the guy did get a dog yeah why
why can't a guy is that dog would starve
first of all it would die first I would
definitely add by the way you're like oh
I'm gonna give it out so I gotta go get
something to eat cuz I'm a car dogs like
you like but how hungry am i and this
dogs like [ __ ] I'm starving I was
telling Jonathan before the podcasts
because I'm a little thin right now that
it's because since I wrecked my car I
never eat because I'm too lazy to go get
food because now I have to either uber
or walk which means it's always like how
hungry am i is it worth going outside so
you're right I probably wouldn't even
feed the dog or I would feed the dog
7-eleven food because that's a block
from my house the dog will be eating
like whatever they have it's a little
mini tacos early dog funeral anyway so
enough about me I'm still disaster I
think I ruined things with that guy but
it's probably for the best
know why
off guy I mean not not though the
celebrity crush wait so the Antonov guy
the guy that we the guy the guy that you
don't think I should date and neither do
any of my friends that guy that I keep
my ruined it I think I did good that
feels good that feels like a win yeah
you know what happened John this is what
it is we talk every day every day no
every day still talk every day right we
have sex he won't let me sleep over
we've been [ __ ] since July he will
not let me sleep over so we had sex the
other night and then he does this move
we're after the sex I'm gonna be honest
with you
that's not his house maybe yeah maybe he
has a cat here's what I don't get
cuz I don't get so he goes away out of
town right he's texting me every day the
whole time he's gone he's even like if
you want to go to my place and use the
pool while I'm gone you can't just not
the bed chains on it yeah like what guy
is like so cool with you that he'll let
you go in his house when he's not even
in the state and use it but he won't let
you spend the night it's such a [ __ ] you
know it's a weird block because I think
what he thinks is that that would mean
you guys are doing that's exactly what I
thought but then he says [ __ ] like he
goes I take girls that I'm just hooking
up without like out of town for the
weekend sometimes like hooking up isn't
like he's basically trying to say
hooking up doesn't mean dating but he
takes hookups on overnight trips
sometimes but then he won't let me spend
the night aching you in it overnight
trip no I've never spent a night with
him ever maybe is it a disgusting habit
he snores or he farts in his sleep maybe
it is I'm history
maybe he sleepwalks oh what's so bad
about that
are you [ __ ] the cat I think is the
cat there's no no captain it doesn't
matter the point is the reason I [ __ ]
it up is because we went out the other
night we had a great time we had great
sex but then he does the thing his move
is after the sex and he gets pissed that
I think this is a move but you know it
is after the sex well the point
[Laughter]
yeah yeah it's called the kite wait what
every guy does this after the sex not
every day he cuddles me for like a half
hour yeah until he he decides like it's
long enough and then he gets up he
always puts on clothes go to the kitchen
and eat something every time no matter
what I could be 3 o'clock in the morning
he's like I'm gonna go grab a snack so
the first time he did it I said to him
you know if you want me to go you can
just tell me you don't have to do this
move where you go stand in the kitchen
so that I come out and leave so then as
you walk into the kitchen while he's
eating he knows your burrs here it's
waiting for you outside it's outside
with the Panda Express deliver take that
ride home so he always offers me food
but this time it was the worst because
we have a sex I'm so tired I'm buzzed we
had gone out for drinks before it's 3:00
a.m. he goes out to get food and he
actually says to me this time remember
last time I went to the kitchen to get
food what happened
because we got in this fight he's like
I'm just going to get food so I'm like
okay so to me I'm like I guess that
means he's just like you can show here
yeah so I'm like cool so I stay in bed I
don't get up good girl he's out there
for like 20 minutes he never came back
and then I started yet to preheat the
oven I should order food before you have
sex own against there's like yeah well I
didn't know what to do so I waited as
long as I felt I could without it being
like super weird just fake your sleep I
saw had a virus but whatever it's too
late now so then I finally went out to
the kitchen
I didn't even argue I just was like I'm
gonna call a car I called uber like
it'll be here in five minutes he's like
you know it's a countdown like he's
trying to act like he doesn't want me to
go yeah but I could tell he's a good
actor yeah does he have a laundry does
he have it
laundry machine there yeah just start a
load of laundry of yours
I don't bring laundry just put my
clothes I'm gonna get a bite Dean you're
like cool I'm gonna go to bed
this is this should be ready in the
morning wait why did you put it on slow
cycle I gotta go to bed I don't want the
lonely no he take eight hours these are
delicates by the way so I left so I left
and then when I got home you know we
start texting no well no he texts me
that's the thing I'll leave and then
he'll text me for another hour hour and
a half always like he doesn't want to
stop talking so then he said something
about the fires and people being
evacuated and I said like well I would
tell you you could come here if you're
evacuating see lives in the hill I was
like but you know I know you'd probably
rather burn alive than spend the night
together yeah and then he was like
hahahahaha
and then I was like but seriously it's
kind of I go it's kind of getting old
like there's nothing worse than being
like buzzed and relaxed and then getting
into a cold uber at 3:00 a.m. yeah you
know and then he was like I didn't ask
you to leave and I was like you don't
there's not gonna be a next time because
this turned into the hugest fight
because he said I didn't ask you to
leave and I'm like but it's obvious and
then he's like this is you making [ __ ]
up in your head and then I'm like this
is obviously a move like you go to the
kitchen every time like this is a guy
move and then he's like well you I've
never slept with a girl who makes such a
big deal about spending the night and
I'm like I've never slept with a guy who
won't let me spend the night like even
just I [ __ ] guys once and slept over
and never seen him again like it's not a
big are you hearing that guys guys hey
will [ __ ] you once I never see you again
it's only happened once and I hope he
comes back to town but um
are you listening stranger but then I
said to him I go the last guy I slept
with spent the night at my house
left in the morning I haven't seen him
since it's not a big deal it doesn't
mean anything and then he's like because
he got murdered that's a that by the way
sounded like the missing persons case
look the way you just started that yeah
and then this guy I never saw
again I item milk Arden I saw but I
didn't know where he went
not a big deal and we're looking Amber
Alerts just let us know I didn't kill
him yet deposition in court and then he
said well the last girl I slept with
bought me dinner afterwards and went
home without a word and she didn't think
it was a bit like it's just like we're
just [ __ ] gonna kill each other and
then we got in a huge fight but that
knows my folks I got super-drunk and
then I did the thing girls do where like
he wasn't responding to me and I was
like [ __ ] you I can't believe you're
ignoring me this is [ __ ] like we
talk every day and you're just gonna
stop answer he really though like stays
up till 4:00 a.m. every night and he
stopped answering me at like 11 o'clock
and then he was like I was asleep and
I'm like you aren't ever asleep at 11
like I knew he's full of [ __ ]
so we got in a huge fight and then he's
like this is just this was supposed to
be casual and it's turning into a whole
thing and then I was like fine then
don't text me and then he goes but I
would like to be friends but I said that
to you before I go we've never been
friends we can't be front you can't go
from [ __ ] to front this is the
longest episode of Dawson's Creek well
the point is I'm gonna start my new plan
is and I already put it into I'm already
doing it I already asked out like four
people I'm just gonna start dating a
whole bunch of guys and you hear that
guy call right now calm down
that's it over I think under 30 days
you'll call it no yeah I'm putting a bet
out there I won't [ __ ] him again anyone
any action this no because spending the
night things do you let girls spend the
night that you don't that you're not in
a relationship with like what's your
deal with yeah why not especially
Jackie's is ready to go to court
instantly every time use up he expects
it by then I guess is covering my paces
covering tracks if you actually think
about that that's a bad sign Jack's like
every girl thinks I raped her I don't
know what the problem no no he's saying
they did he did it they thought I did
but you know what your honor what
done that in the letter say over she
said she said you got up for food yeah
because I was trying to feed her I was
thankful all right Jack Jr I just want
to know like am i nuts like if you're
sleeping with someone for six months and
they they don't sleep over it doesn't
that what does that mean no I think I
mean you know what it is it feels like
the comfortable thing to do to sleep
over like the like that feels like the
natural even if you just like if you had
a one-night stand with somebody like I I
wouldn't kick them out of bed you just
fall asleep yeah by the way if you're
not tired after a sec are you ain't
doing it right
totally so it's like it's like who knows
whatever point is now it's like a
respect thing now I'm like I can't if I
[ __ ] him again now I'm the loser
oh so you said you are under 30 no I
said if I [ __ ] mean it okay I won't
okay what is it December 7th
I don't know before New Year's no no
Christmas there we go you're doing
Christmas Road Christmas I'm doing the
26th through the 1st in Vegas me too oh
I'm the laugh actor he's a driver yeah
where are you
India your life is amazing you talked
about my love life the whole time what's
going on with you guys so you had it you
had a date with you last night but you
always have a cute you you do well no
are you kidding you know you do you
still want to say it I hear no no I
would tell you I mean I'd listen I think
that I will you know me before when I
was on the show I had a girlfriends
consistent yes for a long long time I
think that I am like a
boyfriend/girlfriend person I mean I
remember it's so funny but I was trying
to talk I was talking to some of the
other day about the time right before
the show and even my dating life like I
can't remember do you know because I
feel like my life is not so different
than I'm yeah I'm in India now that's
not it but I mean like I think
everything's sort of changed like we
were talking about
about about being reliant on phones like
before the show started I feel like you
know I don't even have an iPhone before
the show started you're so poor back
then I had no even worse even worse I
had a palm what's that it's mom pilot
yeah but but the phone poem had a phone
for a second and Apple took the
technology the Apple the technology
where you swipe up and get rid of the
cards that was palm so they took it when
they moved operating systems I'm on a
weird show called conspiracy theories no
one gives a [ __ ] about and I hosted it
has one listener me right up there with
your podcast I have so many yeah free
stuff yeah give me free stuff yeah it's
too aggressive um but uh no but I I
think oh I talk about how things have
changed since no I was thing about palme
and I was like why do I have that phone
stolen yes so I question but I think
that I I'm not somebody who I mean I
date but I feel like I'm a boyfriend
kind of guy yeah you seem like a good
boyfriend now yeah cuz you gotta mean as
long as I've known you how long we know
just about five years he's yeah and
about four or five years like that yeah
I think for the majority of the time I
had a girlfriend yeah you seem like the
kind of guy that if you meet someone
that you really like you just go all-in
you wouldn't be like well you don't seem
like a piece of [ __ ] like thank you I'll
take both those compliments yeah I just
I mean the thing is for me that I think
I actually kind of want a relationship
but I'm not like I'm not looking for
women I'm open to it look if I meet
someone I'm the same way you know
because I the thing my biggest issue is
speaking of going out of town we travel
a lot when I'm not here shooting
something my agents try to put me on the
road and I think it's hard to start a
new relationship if you're not in town
yeah like if you were looking to date
somebody who lived here even if they
lived like Hollywood Orange County if
they lived I'm just thinking in the
vicinity and then you were going out on
the road every single week right that's
and you didn't know this person I think
that's a hard thing because I will say
I've met girls in the past like whatever
like eleven months or something and when
the show especially this summer I was at
it I was out of LA for like
I met I will say I met a lot of amazing
people girls that I was like oh this
girl's really cool and then I literally
was gone for a month and then I went
home to spend a lot of times myself
Chicago and so it was a real like I I
had been working which was amazing the
show was great but then we had like we
were like you're not gonna get picked up
again so my perspective sort of changed
I'm like what I can do for the future
and so a lot of me was like well you're
gonna have to be here in September
October November whatever so just get
out of town for the summer and I did a
ton of stand-up I traveled with my
childhood best friend and I spent a ton
of time at home with my family
perfect so like it was a great summer
but then I went looking back on it the
one I mean I remember meeting people and
I was like oh that would have I think in
different circumstances it might have
worked to be honest even this dude the
on/off dude I think that the biggest
issue for us is that we both are gone so
much that every time it starts to get
like we start to fall into a pattern
where it's comfortable and getting like
good one of us leaves and then you know
when there's weeks that go by and you
don't see someone no matter how much you
tax I mean it's just like things start
to creep into your mind it gets weird
and then you see each other it's kind of
a little bit like starting over again
but also it's like you know I feel like
we I'm not like texting isn't a
substitute for reality dankey and I mean
so it's like if I don't see the person
because I've dated people long-distance
I had two girls that I had incredible
feelings for loved them and they were
both in different parts of the country
at the same yeah that's my third podcast
held secret threesome but but you know
what it is and then I remember like I
remember thinking that was the hardest
thing is that you know like even even
with like Skype or FaceTime or whatever
you know if you know cuz one time we got
into a really big argument one of the
girls who was out of town and it was
like yeah we want to make up but like we
won't see each other for two weeks right
yeah it's it's really hard it is hard
really really hard especially if the
person doesn't want to like FaceTime
much I mean then you're like really [ __ ]
I need to see your face but also like I
sort of enjoy like going to them like I
like to go to like I'm saying like the
movies or whatever just like being
around that person if you don't to talk
to them that's like my favorite thing
that's the part that's like the part of
dating that I always want to get to with
people right of course I want to get
past the fun part I'm gonna get to the
part where I can just come over and like
we can just like have Netflix on I be on
my phone you be on your we don't even
have to be talking but you're just kind
of like around each other like your toes
touch each other yeah freezing get the
[ __ ] off right then you [ __ ] a little
and then they call you an uber like that
[ __ ] a little they go to get something
to eat
all right that's that's where I want to
get oh wait i'm there except without the
good part at the beginning except
without the [ __ ] the good part was of
being able to follow but she was the
other night at a bar with her friend so
you're there with your friend at a bar
in public you know what though and I've
said this before and I think Jack can
comment on this I mean it would like
better than I can
you're such a great catch and I'm gonna
say this probably because he doesn't
listen to the podcast but Barack Obama
no no but remember I tried to set you up
with my friend yeah he's so hot no well
that guy for sure but my friend no but
yeah that guy still was hanging out with
you by the way when I go out he won't
mind that we're talking about him right
now
good I'll give you a hint Joe Biden it's
not like pence um but but but but the
first guy who's more of my childhood
friend he's so sweet and you know what
the thing is um he is one of the
greatest human beings you'll ever mean
and he's somebody cuz like he saw I mean
obviously we post a lot of each other on
our social media and stuff so like and
that's how both those guys saw you but
I've had other friends be like oh my god
who is that hot blonde but I've told you
every time yeah and then I and then I
say it's not you are hot but I was like
she's such a great person cuz yet you
and I will go out and Monday nights you
know and just like sitting a diner and
eat after stand-up or we have a great
time yeah and that's what I always tell
them because they first asked like have
you guys ever hooked up and I'm like no
yeah but but I cry when he says that
from happiness cuz she's like I'm like
do you want to spend the night she's
like aren't you gonna get something to
eat
now Mike what's happening and um but uh
but for real like they they I was good
you know what is it's not that it's like
oh you are such a cool person so that's
what you know what sucks is which I have
realizes I've gotten old
when you're with somebody that's an
energy suck and an energy vampire you're
you don't realize it but you're closed
off to UM better not better than that
this person sucks and other people are
great but it's like better for you
opportunities and the problem is is
because we get tunnel vision to fix
problems no rats what you're not trying
to do is date him you're trying to like
fix this prank you're right and you know
what's really weird and then I'm gonna
get off this topic so I have a better
question but what's really weird is he
says to me a lot that I'm not he's like
I just wish you were a happier person
like you're just negative which is
really weird I've never and I've known
you in a many capacities you've always
called me I've talked you through
problems I've never used that to
describe you that's what publicly or
privately not even to myself I've been
like God what is her issue I've never
thought that that's my thing I've never
had anyone in my life when it's about a
guy but even when I mean then you're so
happy yeah you're right because when I
remember when I went home to visit my
dad in July my my dad was sick and so I
remember I was home for that week or
whatever and then you and I were on the
phone and I remember exactly where I was
because I'm I do this walk in my old
neighborhood like it's my old school
from when I was in first grade my
parents they live in the house I grew up
in and so I walked this whole thing I
remember the entire walk it's like two
miles you and I were talking about that
instance yeah and and the whole time I
remember thinking like you are sort of
like you feel bad because you don't know
what to do but you're not mad about it
you're not like like you don't you're
not you don't have like poison in you
I've never even mad at at the guy oh
that's what you didn't get mad you mad
like I have this problem I don't know
what to do exactly it's hardest in this
case cuz it's almost worse with this guy
because he's not being a complete piece
of [ __ ] like it's almost easier like
when they're just an [ __ ] you're like
[ __ ] this guy but because that's a pro
and that's I'm nothing to him you know
that that I've never met him and I told
you that but I would say people who are
middle of the road they're like the
worst because you can't make a
polarizing discipline a leading
polarizing where you can make a
definitive absolutism he does enough
nice carrying around exactly to make me
go
he's not a bad guy he treats me better
than 90% of the guy he's not a cancer
he's a virus yeah you can't beat the
common cold you're right he's the common
cold
I gotta sniff him out and he does I cam
need to put some vape o-x right on the
old ha ha alright well [ __ ] that guy
what was it Russian yeah here's the
question so this is totally unrelated
but it's something that we were talking
kind of about this the other night and I
thought what a great question for the
podcast so I guess I'll have to give
full disclosure for this but like I am
kind of like a freakin bad like I love
everything like I like to try che I like
to be like super kinky dirty I'm up for
almost you couldn't tell it ok the first
podcast and listen to a verse I'm not
like what's weird about me though is
that people get the wrong idea and they
think I'm like that means I'm like crazy
[ __ ] or whatever I'm always partying
but the truth is like I'm selective with
the guys and I'm actually kind of
weirdly old-fashioned in some ways so
this is the question because it eluded
Chris song I am you're a lady in the
street and a frickin the see I kind of
am yeah but here's the question I
sometimes wonder if I'm too freaky
and that's why guys don't see me as a
relationship material like Jack was
saying the other night like he dated a
chick once I was like so filthy in bed
that he's like I couldn't really wife
this chick is such a freak that's you
know it's funny is I'm sending my way no
no but I'm serious like do you think
that if you're to like if I'm really
into a guy like I'll send them videos
guys are a tough thing because I think
that guys have an idea of something and
and I think that that's the problem with
like what's happening with the last
story yes um
the the prequel to this question that um
that people have an idea of thing but
the reality is super different because I
think that like you know guys will watch
a lot of porn or and you know that's it
that that's a good exclusive thing the
guys but guys watch a lot of porn and
they'll be like oh I really like that
but then I think when maybe when they do
it it's kind of like whoa this is a lot
like the fantasy for them is very
different than the reality that's what I
mean so it's almost like I think if you
like if you're too
you open to anything whatever I feel
like maybe in the back of the guy's mind
he's like it depends on what they're
ready for in life because I think like
if you can get to that place with
somebody immediately then I feel like
it's it's two things like if they can
acknowledge that's that that's you being
comfortable that you want to like this
is a part of you and you want to open
this up to them it depends on how they
look at it right because that has to do
with their own hold up you know but not
yours because they have preconceived
notions about people that are like that
instead of looking at you as an
individual being this person it's like
therapy to me don't think that most guys
I mean honestly though don't you think
that most guys have that it's like that
whole like Madonna syndrome right like
they can't see the woman they love as
like a [ __ ] so they don't [ __ ] them the
same way as a girl that's just like
Trojan Trojan thin lines I know what
you're saying I think that that I can't
tell though because I'm wondering if I
should pull back for way longer is what
I'm saying like I'm wondering if I
should hold in the Freak for months um I
mean I already make guys wait like like
I make guys wait awhile now I really
don't [ __ ] them until I'm like if I like
till I'm fat
twice know if I really like them I wait
longer now just because I know me and if
I like them and the sex is amazing
that's when I like really get hooked
yeah so now I'm trying to wait until I
can really tell they're like not someone
that's just trying to [ __ ] yeah but I
mean I don't know maybe I should hold
off on like the nasty videos and like
the crazy [ __ ] in bed until it's like a
year in or some nice too long oh you
don't know I would like a month a month
just say this let me just say you're not
saying that every day no part of it is
like if you do want something yeah you
just introducing it's a it's a it's an
advent calendar it's just new doors of
crazy
together yeah that's what's around your
tree - yeah I do a joke if I do that
about I had an idea about a magician
about that with a vibrator on top of the
tree and anal beads is the girl it's
funnier
anyway yeah I think that you here's the
problem if that's you like I definitely
think that you can parcel out your crazy
I don't think that that not to you I'm
saying that could be a duchess like a
rule of life but but eventually if you
really want to be with somebody you're
not gonna want to like curb who you are
now to be that way and the earlier that
you can go like sometimes I'll do
something not to like test somebody but
if I'm I'll just like be as much me as I
can if I think that it's going that way
because you keep having to push it
because eventually you find because this
has happened to me and with it with an
ex-girlfriend this is a long time ago
she was an alcoholic and she got help
and it was wonderful but she tried to
not hide it but for a long long time she
would sort of I guess hide it cuz she
didn't want it but then like when we got
into three months then she was like oh I
guess this is gonna last then she became
this other thing but I realized later
that's how she always was so then right
away I was like I don't want to be a
part of this like she's a friend she got
help I'm super happy for her but it was
one of those things where I could tell
after the fact like oh you were hiding
this until you thought this was a sure
thing yeah and then it just kind of it
blew up it wasn't great you got to be
the thing that you are some job yeah I
love you for it or they want that's
right and they're right you don't want
to be with somebody who like was like oh
thank god you waited like a year to pull
out those anal beads
josè it'll be doubt date one guy and
honestly I don't perceive them in there
for a year like a girl goes to get her
wallet and she just sets the anal beads
down that's like porno Mary Poppins you
think it's a lamp it's just a dildo out
of the bag that would actually be like a
really funny hidden-camera thing to do
to go on a first date and have a whole
bunch of sex toys in your bag and then
partway through the day it'd be like
your
for something you just set [ __ ] out and
see what the guy does yeah really well
it's it's almost two both you have
auditions I have nothing because my life
is empty but it's fine actually let's
see what is there to plug I'm at the
Comedy Store tonight but this will come
out tomorrow so that doesn't matter
um I don't know I forget where I am this
weekend where am i Friday night in
Whittier uh check my web site Kate
Quigley comm follow me at Kate q funny
guys you got anything you want to plug
coming up
I met the December 15 through 17 that
laughs unlimited in Sacramento is Vegas
25th through the second come see me yet
yeah I think I think I'm at The Improv
this Saturday I don't know well they
offered me a spot and then I confirmed
it but like sometimes I you know I'm
always afraid cuz I guess I try to
confirm it as soon as I see it but
sometimes like last night I was really
tired I was passed out you don't know if
they gave it to someone else yeah so
then I like the first thing I woke up
really early cuz I had a - auditions
today so I was wanted to work on them
and I woke up right away was oh my god
like sorry I'm definitely in for the
show I think you're fine
yeah so I'll be at the improv maybe this
Saturday and then next Monday I'm gonna
be at the I'm gonna be - ha a Monday on
Monday baby boy yeah come Wednesday sir
it's my four-year anniversary doing that
Wednesday's show oh wait 13:13 I'll be
there I'm wearing show we're both on and
then I'm gonna be at the sycamore Tavern
which is there doing the Trevor's during
the new show on Monday upstairs yeah
yeah it's fun I mean you met it's a good
minute that I usually call of course it
it yeah it's so funny that's where we
met at happy endings and by the way it
is Saturday night if you don't do the
improv or after that is my free night so
if I don't go on the date with my
celebrity crush cat guy we should set it
up with your hot friend
well you I'm gonna go see the disaster
artist I don't know what that is
it's the Seth Rogen and James Franco
moving
I thought it was like a magician I did
some ADR for it and so yeah the events
they have to change swear words for
television and for airplanes yeah and so
I went in and did Seth Rogen that's
amazing yeah you're so talented
well thank you you ever pretend to be
Seth Rogen in bed only when I'm coming
[Laughter]
as a great Edna that was up really the
perfect ending for the podcast coming by
the way it's a super funny movie like
you should you would see it you'll love
it okay yeah yeah you would love it will
you get out of our way Jack so we can
okay all right listen everyone come to
the haha next Wednesday December 13th
we'll all be there and thank you guys
for listening please follow Jonathan
kite Jack junior and check out my
patreon patreon comback slash KQ funny
and don't forget to check out that quip
toothbrush and get your discount love
you guys bye
[Music]